let's pull up this tweet real quick and
we'll talk about this from MSNBC God
bless they write disabled Americans have
the right to be represented and most
importantly to work and that includes
working for the US government so we've
gone from he's not disabled to he is
disabled and that means he has a right
to work for the government in the span
of what 12 hours
I mean the big leap right this isn't
like like okay so like Greg Abbott's in
a wheelchair that's when I hear disabled
that's kind of what I think about when
someone's got neurological damage like
fetterman when they can't actually and
by the way who was the uh who was the
MSNBC journalist who they went after her
like crazy she was 100
yeah she was the only one okay she was
the only one who told the truth I'm not
an only person and and she was attacked
for it she was excoriated for it and she
was proven 100 what did she say she said
that she this guy can't hold a
conversation without the use of these
computer I wanna I wanna tell you it is
not an auditory issue they're lying and
I can give you one I can cite an easy
example from the debate that proves it
is actually cognitive impairment when he
said hi good night everyone yeah now
hold on yeah he didn't accidentally say
goodbye what happened was his brain
understands that evening and night are
are synonymous
but it didn't understand that good night
and good evening are opposites right
that is cognitive impairment like his
brain was able to recall the word and
then said the wrong one in that context
that is cognitive impairment
so when you know and and we've been
discussing this so have you heard what
what Bannon did over on war room to
cover this no so this is hilarious um
but it's it's very insightful as well so
he's been really really focused on
transhumanism and this whole idea of man
machine merger and so he's taken his
transhumanist editor Joe Allen and he
sent him up to Pennsylvania to cover
fetterman as the world's first cyborg
candidate
because when you look at it this this is
like a prototype that they're trying to
roll out now obviously the tech isn't
quite there yet but they're trying to
see that they can get away with actually
hooking someone's mind up to a computer
and then running them as a candidate and
my question is now we saw this with
closed captioning are they going to come
out next and say well you know it's
really not fair to only give him the
closed captioning we should be able to
give him multiple choice answers that
the computer feeds him you know based on
uh position statements and policy papers
or he can choose from or wait to the
point where they they wheel in on a
hospital bed a totally paralyzed person
who's just not moving and then it rolls
up and there's like a an electrode going
into the brainstem hello I am John
Federman I am running for Senate vote
for me why not just make it really
obvious and get a mannequin and a puppet
I think that would be more I said that
was much better than your Elon Musk oh
yeah the computer that was actually
pretty good robot voice most kind of
hard to in person it's very hard to
pursue yeah they're all puppets well I
mean in this case in this case this is
why then the regime wants people like
fetterman like Joe Biden because they
don't want someone up there who's
actually asking questions they don't
want someone up there who's got you know
like like look at Blake Masters right
you put Blake Masters in a room that
guy's gonna be asking questions he's
going to say how does this work where
does the money come from all this
fetterman's gonna say
green yes yes Schumer what do you want
yes and that's it that's all he's going
to do my favorite part of the fetterman
debate was when he said quote I want to
look every woman in Pennsylvania stray
in the face
and that was the sentence could you
imagine how terrifying that would be for
the women of Pennsylvania yeah my mom
sat down for that I would definitely you
know I'm running the eyes campaign I'm
running that quote just over fetterman's
face over like over and over again
randomly yelled out Doug mastriano
but yeah he did but my favorite question
tonight was when asked about whether he
supported fracking or not he said yeah I
support fracking and I don't I don't and
I support fracking and I support Frankie
so here's my analysis this is my mind
he said I support fracking okay that's
it that's positive and I don't I don't
that's two negatives but then he said
and I support fracking and I support
fracking so when you add those together
you get one statement of I support
tracking so he does support fragrance so
because the question actually doesn't
support fracking for the fact Checkers
he doesn't support fracking that was the
question was that they they pointed out
they were like John we have you on
record a couple years ago saying that
you don't support fracking we have this
this uh
you know was it a letter that he signed
open letter that he signed pledging to
ban fracking from a couple years ago
he's going to and they said well John
can you explain this and my take on it
was so like oh you're consultant right
let's say you're working for fetterman
you know that question's coming up at
the debate you know that fracking is so
important mastriano was was In This Very
Room talking about how we got to build
pipelines to Erie pipelines to
Philadelphia fracking all over the place
Marcella Shale Etc so you know this is
coming up in the people of Pennsylvania
won it you would have had a prepared and
some kind of way to deal with this and
it seemed to me like it was sort of like
his he went okay mind search for answer
and he just it just came up this glaring
404 error 404 error but he knew that the
answer was that he had to say that he
supported it so he just straight up went
with it well if I was fetterman's
consultant there's no way in hell I
would have let that guy on stage like
what I'm not saying you yeah yeah
that just sunk the race and there was
polling that came out uh today uh an
October 25 Poll and it had eyes up three
and that was before the debate and so
it's not gonna it's not gonna end well
here for
um the first cyborg candidate uh I think
it was a failed experiment first world's
first they should they should shut this
this program down
which party will win the U.S Senate
election in Pennsylvania in 2022 take a
look at that
I mean there you go The Biggest Loser of
this all Alicia is Conor lamb and I
think that's seriously you don't talk
about that enough look at that right
there that's the debate you know when
Connor lamp first won
you know what was that 2016 or 2014 Jack
that was 18. well he he was basically
like this is the next Boy Wonder this is
our next Obama and he loses to John
fetterman well because he was one of
those he was like the blue dog Democrat
yeah right he was one of those because
he was a uh he was Marine right uh he's
always a marine he was in Western
Pennsylvania he beats Keith rothfuss so
a guy who was in like a trumpy area of
Pennsylvania but is able to pick up
those sort of they call him the Reagan
democrats he might just start calling
the Trump Democrats now but he's able to
win them over by saying hey I'm a
Democrat but I'm not as I'm not part of
the Slime and the sludge right but the
problem is their primary base for the
entire state of Pennsylvania once that
uh and doesn't like somebody who served
in the military I mean like a like a
colonizer and a murderer and a baby
killer and all these things and so they
reject him he's sitting there cooling
his heels now having to watch this
entire debacle day in day out they like
him they like John fetterman the man who
chased down that unarmed black man with
a shotgun when he was the mayor of that
that small town that was insane he
defended it defended it was
yeah what though he was out I was
keeping things safe or something like
that I was just keeping to everyone in
my town they understood what that was
about and I like yeah I mean I think we
all understand what that was about John
wow
but have you seen the so they want to
switch him out they want to switch them
out this is what they want to do they
want to set it up and the state of
Pennsylvania we've already got some
issues on this and and Luke you
mentioned a little bit um before the
show but they've already said they're
talking the Secretary of State acting
Secretary of State Lee Chapman is now
saying well we may have a bit of a delay
after election night and the state
Republicans now have already put forward
a letter saying why did you send out a
quarter of a million mail-in ballots
without verifying the identity of the
people you were sending them to First
the way you're supposed to Under
Pennsylvania State Law that's a huge red
flag and now you're in a situation where
if if Shapiro wins and fetterman wins
fetterman I I guarantee you will not
serve a day in the Senate and Shapiro
will pick someone or actually Tom Wolf
will probably just pick someone in the
lame duck session and my money would be
on the wife on Giselle Republicans need
to sue in Pennsylvania right now to
demand an election day limit
that's it you do not count ballots after
election day the Constitution prescribes
a single day for the election soon now
and then you know because I think the
Supreme Court's still Democrat leaning
if if in Pennsylvania in Pennsylvania
yeah if it gets rejected you can cite
that and appeal and be like hey we
started this fight before the election
keeping with that the United States
Supreme Court has a ruling out on
Pennsylvania when it comes to this
because Pennsylvania was saying hey
we'll accept your ballots even if
they're undated even if they're undated
whereas everyone knows no that's that's
not how that works it has to be signed
has to be dated correct mailing address
verified identity all of it that's
Pennsylvania State Law Pennsylvania
secretary of state says no go ahead and
send those in on Data in the
Pennsylvania Attorney General who is
Josh Shapiro is running for governor
could not care less and so they've come
out at the state of Pennsylvania level
saying we don't care what the United
States Supreme Court says we'll accept
the ballots either way and here's the
problem once you separate that ballot
from the secrecy envelope once you
separate it from the outer envelope and
put that ballot in there's no
identifying information on it it's going
to go right in with all the other
ballots you know I just realized about
fetterman's cognitive impairment is that
it works out really really well if you
think about it most people didn't watch
that debate now what can you do
if fetterman is asked a question right
so actually Jack let's let's play ask me
if I support fracking uh uh Tim do you
do you support fracking I absolutely
support fracking but I don't support
fracking next question
and now here's what you do maybe you
just no I I but you heard my answer
because now my campaign can take both
Clips right right and send the I support
to the areas where it's big and I
opposed to the urban centers and you get
them all but you were so articulate like
fetterman can't say it like that no I
know I'm saying think about what he's
discovered on accident right so now
you're gonna have future candidates
being like I believe we should be
raising taxes on the wealthy wow I also
believe we should be cutting taxes on
our on our principal job creators no no
Mr fetterman what's your what's your
stance on abortion Mr fetterman I am
absolutely pro-choice and I believe
abortion is wrong and I am pro-life now
what about these what about these these
child uh gender transitions I 100
support gender affirming care for
children and I believe the state should
not allow doctors to perform child sex
change final question Second Amendment
Second Amendment is Miss religion
Governor I support the Second Amendment
rights of all of the people in this
state in this country
and I think we need Swift gun control
and gun reform to prevent violent
offenders and people who shouldn't have
guns from having them which means a ban
on large capacity magazines and assault
weapons and then you just clip whatever
you need social media audience
you can feel free to use that one for in
the future politicians you know I I may
have been I I may be hitting gold here
right I kind of feel like fetterman gets
the credit federal well I mean with with
Hillary Clinton putting the fake accent
and AOC doing it yeah that's what
politicians do anyway they tell you what
they people want to hear they lie they
they make promises they can't keep they
say yeah I support this if enough people
want it and then when they get into
office they go to all the lobbyists they
go to all the multinational corporations
and bankers and they're like just tell
me what to do they're like okay and they
carry out those orders screwing you over
yeah that's Second Amendment impression
you just did sounded like just like John
cornyn senator from Texas is that what
he did oh my God the great state of
Texas they love their guns they are so
proud of their great too up until this
last convention and then you have a guy
named John cornyn who gets elected says
I you know defend your 2A and then you
have the Republican senator from Texas
that's tapped by Mitch McConnell to
negotiate with the Democrats a bill to
take away the Second Amendment rights of
the American citizens all right he got
booed off the stage now if I was
running and I was on a debate stage ask
me if I support the Second Amendment
Rita you Tim are you fetterman not me
I'm me Tim do you support the Second
Amendment I do and if elected I will
work to repeal all gun control laws as
all of them are unconstitutional that
includes the NFA and I want to make sure
everyone here is fully aware that I
believe the second amendment protects
your right to keep nuclear weapons and
biological weapons as well next question
the Wuhan Doctrine I'm I'm dead serious
you want to amend the Constitution by
all means amend the Constitution is a
process for it but the rights keeping
bear arms included cannons and warships
right and still does this is when I said
this and like all the lefties got really
mad they were like too much tenants are
not illegal you can they're not illegal
but not only that it is private
companies that have all of these these
weapons anyway it is it is private firms
that are funding bio weapons it is
private companies that are making nukes
and other bombs it's not like it's just
the government that has nukes these
people don't understand what's going on
yeah the US government went to Echo
Health Alliance and they're like please
give us your notes about what you were
doing doing at the Wuhan Institute right
before the coronavirus outbreak and Echo
Health Alliance said screw you we're a
private entity we could do what we want
we're not giving you those notes and
they didn't boom so so who do you think
makes the nuclear weapons it's like do
people think the government right now
has like an arms division of scientists
that are manufactured in a manufacturing
base that's making nuclear weapons or
the bio weapons or the artificial
intelligence or the latest next
technology that we don't even know about
that could wipe out Humanity but but in
in a pragmatic sense when you're looking
at some of these companies If This Were
Russia or China we would automatically
Define these companies as extensions of
the government right and so when it
comes to the United States we play this
this game that oh these are private
entities even if look at a company like
Boeing right this is a company where by
and large it's obviously an extension of
the US government when you look at some
of the way that even big Tech the way
that a lot of big Tech works because
they've been given so many deals but
because they will clearly work with
government at a very high level which
we've seen in lawsuit after lawsuit that
it's it's kind of silly for us to say oh
these are completely separate from
government when they obviously have so
much connective tissue thanks for
checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there